-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
"The Tonight Show," you made it.
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, today the U.S.
hit the debt ceiling,
which means
the federal government
can't borrow any more money.
Yep.
Right now the U.S.
is $31 trillion in debt.
The country's
so strapped for cash,
George Santos is e-mailing
people
pretending to be
a Nigerian prince.
[ Laughter ]
Trying.
Also to make some extra money,
it's now called the Gillette
Mach3 Washington Monument.
Which I think is...
[ Laughter ]
But Republicans say they won't
raise the debt ceiling
unless there are
drastic spending cuts.
They even want us to switch our
nukes to store-brand uranium.
I mean, come on.
[ Laughter ]
Today, Treasury Secretary
Janet Yellen said
extraordinary measures
are being taken
to keep the government's
bills paid.
Which explains why tonight Mitch
McConnell started an OnlyFans.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-That's right.
Everyone wants to chip in.
Today President Biden said he
was gonna have a garage sale,
but his garage is a crime scene,
so it's just like --
He can't --
[ Laughter, audience "oohs" ]
[ Rimshot ]
Speaking of classified
documents,
former President Trump has now
claimed that he never took any,
just the empty folders
the documents were in
because they were
"cool keepsakes."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, because there's no cooler
keepsake than a manila folder.
Yeah, it's like, that's --
"cool keepsakes."
Trump takes classified documents
the way we take shampoo
from our hotel rooms, like --
[ Laughter ]
Always nice to pick up
a little reminder
from that time you were the
president of the United States.
The White House
has a gift shop, man.
I mean, you don't go around
grabbing stuff
like you're on "Supermarket
Sweep," you know?
Just taking stuff.
[ Laughter ]
In fairness, when Trump sees the
word classified,
he thinks it just means the
thing has been made more classy.
[ Laughter ]
"That casino was a dump
'til I classified the joint.
And now, it's very classy."
[ Light laughter ]
People are talking about this --
Ukrainian President Zelenskyy
said that he isn't sure
if Vladimir Putin
is still alive.
[ Audience "oohs" ]
Right now, 20 Russian officials
are sitting around a conference
table like,
"You poke him."
"No, you."
[ Laughter ]
Then an aide felt
Putin's forehead, he's like,
"He's cold and stiff,
so all good. He's great."
[ Laughter ]
You guys see this?
At JFK airport here in New York,
a JetBlue plane
accidentally bumped into
another JetBlue plane
that was parked on the runway.
Everyone's okay, and JetBlue
has even released an apology.
Here it is.
-We here at JetBlue
would like to apologize
for our recent misstep.
We take the safety of our
passengers very seriously,
and this kind of careless
accident will not be tolerated.
But look on the bright side.
At least we aren't Spirit.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
[ Applause ]
-Wow. And that's --
-Indeed.
[ Applause ]
-Then -- Then Spirit
saw JetBlue's video,
and released their own response.
Check this out.
-We here at Spirit
don't appreciate
the baseless finger-pointing
and mudslinging that certain
airlines find acceptable.
We promise to never
sink to their level,
because at the end of the day,
at least we aren't Southwest.
[ Laughter ]
-This is -- This is --
I can't believe they did that.
Well, Southwest
saw Spirit's video.
-Really?
-And they released their own.
Watch this.
-We here at Southwest understand
the criticism
we've recently received.
Do we make mistakes? Sure.
But when all is said and done,
at least we aren't Southwest.
Wait, no!
-That -- Well --
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rim shot ]
[ Cheers ]
Hey, I just saw
that Instagram just announced
a new feature called
"Quiet Mode,"
which helps users focus
by pausing all notifications
from the app.
Yeah, here's how it works.
You set your Instagram
to Quiet Mode.
Then a friend texts you,
"Hey, did you see that thing
I sent you on Instagram?"
[ Laughter ]
Some more business news, Party
City just filed for bankruptcy.
[ Audience "aws" ]
Yeah, apparently they just
couldn't keep up with inflation,
weak sales,
and the rising price of helium.
It is tough news.
Let's take
a look at how it's going
over at Party City headquarters.
[ High-pitched ] Well, Dale,
looks like the end of the road.
The price of helium's
just way too high.
-[ High-pitched ]
It's terrible, Doug.
When I heard the news,
I shrieked.
-It's not your fault.
I mean, we expanded too fast,
and it all just went pop.
-And now, it's all coming
to a screeching halt.
-Well, I guess
we can't do this anymore.
[ Hissing, knob squeaks ]
[ Deep voice ] It's a sad day.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Deep voice ] I'm devastated.
-I was waiting for a special
occasion to do this, but --
-Is that a cigar?
-Sure.
-Wait, no!
[ Explosion ]
-Oh, terrible. Oh.
[ Applause ]
That's unfort-- terrible.
[ Laughs ] What?
-Wow.
-Wow!
-They were blonde?
-Oh, terrible.
-They were all blonde?
-Oh, my goodness.
It's Party City, man.
What are you talking about?
Of course.
-And helium suddenly
became flammable?
-Yes, helium's flammable,
very, yeah.
Switching gears, PetSmart
is offering to pay
one dog and one cat $10,000
to serve
as the chief toy tester.
Pretty exciting opportunity.
Here's what some pets had to say
when they heard the news.
This dog said...
This next dog said...
And finally, this cat said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Chief toy tester.
Some movie news,
James Cameron said
that in
the next "Avatar" sequel,
the narrator
will no longer be Jake Sully,
but someone else.
Well, they're trying out
new narrators now,
and we got a sneak peek
of the auditions.
Yep, there's some familiar faces
here. Here. Check this out.
-Look at those blue guys horsing
around in the swimming hole.
You know, I went to
a high school with a Na'vi.
We called him Bluey.
He was 10 feet tall.
Took our basketball team
to the states,
but we got disqualified
because of his gills.
-Wow! Oh, gosh, these fish.
They're trying to murder me.
-The connection between these
here Na'vi and the water
is profound and stirring.
Much like marmalade
on a warm biscuit.
-Wow-e-wow.
I can not believe the amazing
scenery and "Na'veye" people.
Like for part two.
-The Na'vi swim peacefully
underwater as they wonder --
"Where are the [bleep]
penguins?"
-What?
"Where are the penguins?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, I heard that in an effort
to reduce methane emissions,
one dairy company is putting
masks and diapers on cows
to trap their flatulence
and burps.
Someone definitely
suggested this
right after the boss was like,
"Remember, there are
no dumb ideas, okay?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a new study found
that men who use Viagra
are more likely to live longer.
The worse part,
Joe Biden is using the news
to reassure everyone
that he can serve another term.